Alright folks, welcome back.
This is the 2022 ICT mentorship on YouTube and this lesson is going to be intraday overflow
and understanding the daily range.
Alright folks, we're looking at TradingView.com and you can use this platform for free.
There are some benefits to having a membership there.
It's not terribly expensive but nonetheless it provides you a means of looking at charts
that I show in my mentorship here and in my private mentorship group.
So it's the same charts that I'm producing for that community that I'm producing for
you as well.
Everything in this lecture is going to be predominantly around teaching you the elements
of the e-mini, setting up your daily range and your intraday layouts and I'll talk a
little bit about daily profiles so that will help you.
And I'll compare and contrast showing you what it is that you're trying to learn from
me here versus what is available out there on the internet.
So that way you can decide whether or not this is going to be a worthwhile pursuit for you.
These things that I'm teaching today are directly linked to index futures like S&P, Nasdaq and
the Dow.
You can use the Russell 2000.
Those are the markets that I'm targeting with the lessons.
The ideas of trading the Asian range and things like that, they are not applicable to these
markets.
I don't teach that to my students.
I want you to just focus on the things that I'm going to show you in this mentorship.
First things first, I'm going to get the boring stuff right out of the way.
Whenever you're looking at futures, especially the index futures, these contracts trade with
expiration dates and the months that they trade are going to be shown here.
E.S. is the symbol for E-mini S&P, H in this example stands for March.
So the delivery month codes for the commodity markets, H is always representing the month
of March, M is June, U is September, Z is December.
These are the only four months that the index futures trade on E-mini S&P, E-mini Nasdaq
and E-mini Dow.
The year obviously is what it is.
Now if you're going to be using like for instance when I take live trades in the TD Ameritrade,
they don't take their year symbol like this, it's 22.
But in trading view, if you're pulling up a symbol like I have here, E-S-H-2-0-2-2,
that represents the E-mini S&P 500 contract for delivery month, March, year 2022.
Since they expire, it's important for you to know that the third Friday of the month
of delivery, which is obviously in this example here, March, the third Friday of that month
is expiration.
You do not want to be trading after expiration and the question is going to be is when do
I start trading the next month out?
This is always going to be the front month or the current month or nearby contract.
The month after the front month or current contract month is always going to be referred
to by me as the next month out.
If you ever have a doubt, you can go to Barshark.com and you can go to the select commodity tab
here.
This is all free.
You can scrub down into this list here.
Go to S&P 500 E-mini, click on that.
It'll open up what I just showed you there.
The first one, that's the cash.
You don't want to look at that.
The next contract available is March.
See that?
It even gives you the little cheat.
Right now, this is considered the front month or nearby contract.
The open interest is what I'm watching.
One week before expiration, which is the third Friday of the delivery contract month, so
third Friday of March, third Friday of June, third Friday of September, third Friday of
December, roll over to a new year, starts the sequence all over again, March, June,
September, December.
Real easy pattern, real easy means of keeping track of where you're supposed to be at.
But usually around the first or second day of the week prior to expiration, I start
monitoring open interest and I want to be in the month that has the larger open interest
number.
Notice that the June contract only has 57,310 contracts of open interest.
Right now, the front month or nearby contract of March 2022 has open interest of 2.2 million.
So this is the larger liquidity base contract month.
So I want to be trading this month.
If it becomes a matter of this month here has larger open interest than this one here,
then I'm going to be trading the next month out because I want the liquidity that's available
in the larger pool liquidity offered by the most traded contract month.
Okay, so hopefully that answered that question.
I have a lot of questions regarding that.
Alright, so now what we're looking for is an opportunity and I'm going to teach bias
and specific entry techniques next week.
This week I'm teaching you the intraday framework and I want you to start thinking about market
profiles and you're going to have homework assignments obviously for that at the end
of this video.
We're going to assume that you were bullish in here.
I'm going to provide proof in this video that I was bullish and I did execute with that
bias in mind, but just kind of put that to the sideline.
Some of you are very anxious and you're leaving comments saying can you teach me how to get
in, what am I looking for?
I understand your excitement, but take the lessons at the pace that I'm giving you because
I'm giving you homework assignments and studying so that way it helps build and ingrain the
understanding I'm giving you because your study time is actually going to be where the
majority of your learning is going to come from.
I'm just giving you points of reference so that way you can go in and start looking at
things and start seeing a reoccurring, repeating phenomenon, but I want to take a look at the
15 minute time frame.
When you're looking at this 15 minute time frame, this is the bellwether time frame,
this is where I'm looking for key highs and lows, I'm looking for imbalances like fair
value gaps and things of that nature.
Yes, I will look for order blocks, but I'm going to try to stay away from order blocks
in this lesson, in this mentorship really, because I have models that don't even rely
on order blocks, obviously I'm teaching fair value gap here and that is the main focus
because it repeats, it's an easy pattern, it's there a lot, but I want you to think
about how you frame your day, so when you're in TradingView, or you can do this in your
own platform if you're not using TradingView, but I'm recommending, at least while you're
going through mentorship here on YouTube, to go through the process with TradingView.
This is what you would classically see annotated in my chart for a Forex setup, I'm taking
you to 830, I'm going to put a vertical line there at 830, click this, clone, I know this
is very boring for some of you, because you really want to just get in there and get into
nuts and bolts, but I have new people watching the same video, so I have to make this as
complete as possible and try to cover all the bases, and then hopefully I don't get
as many emails, because I can't keep up with them, and so if you email me and I'm not responding,
I apologize, but I just, I can't keep up with it, all right, so we're looking at, there
we go, that's good, all right, so equal distance in time in the morning, then an hour lunch,
New York lunch, and then an equal amount of time after that, okay, so I'm going to zoom
in here, and in your mind, I want you to think about that lunch hour, and this is always
New York local time, okay, set your TradingView chart to this, if you do that, no matter where
you are in the world, you'll be able to calibrate your local time with this, okay, everything
I'm showing you is directly linked to New York local time, if you do it with any other
time frame, you're going to mess up, you won't have the same calibrations as all my students
and what I'm looking at in price, because eventually I'm going to be showing you charts
on my community tab that I want you to be watching before it happens, but before I even
start doing that, I'm not going to create a train wreck by having everybody looking
at charts in their own local time, and not New York time, and completely miss the point
and plot, so once we have this, I want you to think of this hour here, noon to one o'clock
in the afternoon, New York time, that is a no trade time period, I don't care who tells
you that they can do this and do that, if you're learning from me, just don't trade
during that time, okay, not even in demo, because just trust me, don't do it, okay,
as we go through the mentorship, you'll understand more reasons why I just can't give everything
in one video, obviously, I want to, and I want to do four hour long teachings, but I'm
trying to make them palatable, because I know majority of you don't have the attention span,
because you're new, and you're just now discovering, so I'm trying to bear that in mind when I'm
making these presentations, so you have your daily range on an intraday basis, all set
up and laid out, so these are your boundaries, your morning trade is between 830 in the morning,
why, because there's news events that come out at 830, all the way to noon, preferably
around 11 o'clock, I generally don't like to take trades after 11 o'clock in the morning,
it doesn't mean I haven't, or that I won't, I just generally try not to, I want to try
to be positioned before 11 o'clock and hopefully be writing something into the New York lunch
at noon, and then squaring positions or taking some off if I'm going to hold through the
lunch and anticipate something going through to the close, and we'll talk about that when
we get into profiles, not volume profile, okay, the idea of the afternoon session, I
wasn't going to teach that, but because I see a lot of nonsense on YouTube, I'm just
going to teach it to you, okay, so it's going to be a complete daily treatise on the entire
daily range of indices, so that way, if your interest is in this asset class, you'll have
a far better chance of being successful, in my opinion, using the information I'm going
to give you, okay, and I'm proving it with actual executions, as you'll see later in
the video.
Alright, so we're looking at prior to 8.30, what are you looking for, okay, I got a lot
of questions in the comments section, I'm reading all the comments, folks, I love it
because it's real short little snippets, I know a lot of my students, they like to send
me these really long-winded appreciative emails, and then they give me one chart that doesn't
really explain much to me, and I can't really answer it, so the comments section that I'm
opening up on every one of these videos, if you haven't noticed, I'm allowing one comment
to kind of like honour those individuals that are showing appreciation, and they're not
gratuitously looking to praise me, I don't like that, okay, I like the appreciation for
my time and energy and sacrifice, giving it to you for free, but I don't want to be worshipped,
okay, I don't want all that kind of stuff, don't call me the GOAT, don't call me the
greatest of all time, I don't like that kind of stuff, but if you have something that you
want me to touch on and improve a delivery or explanation of a specific thing I mentioned
in a video, I may already have something in a future lesson planned, but if it's something
that I don't have in my outline that's going to be in future videos, I'll utilise the feedback
I get, okay, so that way, I understand some of you want everything all at one time, and
there's no way I can do all of that in one time, but I am taking the feedback I'm getting
from you all, and I'm using that, okay, but one of the questions I got was, what highs
and lows are we looking for, that, you know, a stop run would be framed on, or what would
be the catalyst for a stop hunt, well, prior to 8.30, if you look at that, okay, we'll
just grab a horizontal ray, and we see this high here, and I'm utilising this with the
benefit of hindsight, because this is how you're going to go back and back test everything,
I want you to take a look at the high here, and the low right here, so prior to 8.30,
in other words, to the left of that, on a 15 minute time frame, what's the most significant
or obvious swing high and swing low, swing high is this, it's a candle with a lower high
to the left of it, and a lower high to the right of it, three candle pattern, okay, it
does not matter if the candles are up or down closes, you're just looking for a swing high,
because above that's going to be buy side liquidity, or buy stops, and a swing low prior
to 8.30, that's a candle that has a higher low to the left and a higher low to the right
of it, it's three candles, again, it does not matter what the close of the candles are,
it has absolutely no bearing on what I'm showing you here, because the swing points are where
liquidity is going to be placed, okay, so once you have these levels on your chart on
a 15 minute time frame, then you can drop down into your first lower time frame for
entry, that's your 5 minute chart, so let's do that now, all these things will be transposed
right to the 5 minute chart, you won't lose anything in case you're wondering, a lot of
new people are afraid if they do something with the time frame, they'll lose their annotations,
alright, so now we have this old high back here, look at this price right there, okay,
that's going to be the high price, on that particular candle right there, it's 45.14
and a half, this candle trades to 45.14 and a half, exactly the same high, when we have
that but look closer, we have relative equal high, but we have it in multiple short term
highs that keep going higher, if there's three highs that go up like that, that's a classic
three drives pattern, there's a book I really enjoyed when I was in the 90s, Linda Rasch
and Larry Connors Street Smarts book, really nice little book, I don't like everything
in the book but I liked a few of the things that they talked about and it helped me understand
stop hunts because I couldn't understand it as a developing student that why would the
price want to go for those stops, it didn't make any sense because the books that I had
bought never really explained all that in detail, they just said trust this pattern
of continuation or reversal pattern and the idea of stop hunts or raids on liquidity never
really came up, so it was an alien topic to me, so when I started delving into the charts
and started looking at it, it helped me and the pattern that she and Larry mentioned in
there was the three little endings pattern, it sounds quirky, it sounds a little silly
but it's basically the three drives pattern, that means it's a swing high, a higher swing
high and a higher swing high, so it's three times that market kept pressing up, I like
to see this pattern forming when there's an old high back here, on any time frame, it's
universal, but if you ever start seeing these three drives up into an old high, you don't
have to see that third high take out the old high because what it's doing is it's already
pressing into running out liquidity, every time it creates a swing high and it starts
to go down, bears are trying to sell that and they're putting buy stops above the previous
high and they keep getting taken, so it's already building in liquidity and informed
investors or quote unquote smart money will be already establishing short positions, then
the market breaks, in one of the previous videos I talked about the pattern or the setup
and I suggested not using a particular swing low that looks like it's been violated and
why didn't that trade work out, wouldn't that be a losing trade, I want you to think
about this idea that I teach which is displacement, okay, if you have a children's swimming pool,
okay, if you have a children's swimming pool in your backyard and you fill it up and then
you have an elephant just fall down inside of it, what's going to happen, the water's
going to be displaced, it's going to be an obvious displacement of that water, rather
simplistic analogy, but that's what you're looking for in price, when price goes above
an old high and it trades down below it, you want to see an obvious displacement, you don't
want to see it just do like a little lethargic run here, that's not enough, this is like
that elephant falling into that children's swimming pool, it's no doubt about it, it
really had a displacement, when that occurs then you go in and you start looking for the
fair value gap, the low, the high and if it trades back up into that then you can look
for a short, okay, there's a process that you go through learning it and it's good that
three of you were very critical about it but trust me, there's rules for a reason and I'm
not trying to hide failure because these patterns sometimes will fail you, okay, you'll read
them wrong or they just won't work, okay, sometimes the market will have some kind of
a news event that comes out or it just simply just rolls over top of it and goes higher
or goes lower, that's a losing trade, that's why you have to have a stop loss, that's why
you have to have good sound money management because if you don't have those things, Murphy's
Law is going to creep in and whatever can go wrong will and if you leave it open to
the market's determination how bad the pain is going to be, trust me, you don't want that,
okay, you want to limit that, so now we have this previous high, previous low, now if we
did not, this is really important that you understand this part here, if we don't start
seeing these higher highs forming and it's just one steady run up, then you anticipate
a high like this to be taken out and it doesn't need to be taken out by much, just trade above
it and then you want to look for this energetic movement lower, that's displacement where
it's really animated, so in other words it would look like when you look at your chart,
that's a little bit more pronounced because it went above this previous high here, you're
looking at this one but as it's starting to move towards that old high, remember 830,
prior to that you're looking for, what's this, 830 swing high, yes, so it's trading
above it here, does it have an energetic break below that, no, it's just a very weak anemic
move lower, then you have another run higher here and then you have this wick or tail come
down and it quickly snaps back, does that create a fair value gap in that, no, it's
not there yet, then it goes higher here, doesn't go above, it matches that high but then now
this high, watch, does it go below that, yes, a little bit here but it's a little anemic
still but then look what we have here, it trades up and then smashes down, then the
next candle here closes, what do we have, there's your fair value gap, that's your short
and you could reach for the liquidity resting below that low that you would be identifying
prior to 830, so sell side liquidity matching up with your short, you sell, you want to
buy it back to cover that short, well here's waiting sellers right down here in the form
of sell stops, bam, hits it, okay, putting aside that you may not have seen this as a
long entry, okay, maybe you didn't see this as a potential continuation of bullishness
but look at these highs here, what's resting above that now, buy stops, buy side liquidity
and then what do we have here right before lunch hour, it goes slightly above it and
then trades down and then we're in that time of the day, you don't trade it, New York lunch
hour, noon to 1, don't trade it, okay, do not trade it, it can do a lot of weird things
in that hour or simply do nothing and go sideways but either way you don't want to be a participant
in that because it's just, it's not usually a clean time of day for price action, so now
here we have the high of the day and all the liquidity resting above here that would not
have been tagged by this, in other words stops that are resting a little bit above that because
there's a lot of people trying to sell short, they want to see this thing go lower but we
created a very important low last week and the market has already tanked a lot so it's
pulling back up in the run that it created going lower on a daily chart, so all these
buy side liquidity pulls here are going to be a reason for the market to want to reach
up to that because you don't have to be a participant down here as a buyer, you just
need to know on the other side of lunch at 1 o'clock, start watching and see is there
an indication that this thing wants to go higher, as you can see all the buy side liquidity
here was ran aggressively here but then the market trades right into the close aggressively
bullish, small little retracement here, small little retracement here and then immediate
run rate into the close, now obviously the market trades a little bit beyond that but
this time of day expect whatever algorithms that you would expect to be driving price
and price runs to pretty much cap the majority of the volume that's going to be in that day,
so what I want you to think about is how the days designed to have a morning move, a lunch
hour where you don't want to be trading and then the afternoon move, go back through your
charts and you can go back as far as you want, the more you do this the better you'll get
but I want you to think about creating your charts like this and then describing what
the morning trend was, was it a bullish move, was it a bearish move, was it consolidation,
if it was consolidation prior to that part of the day in other words the previous day
or the previous days was it bullish or bearish then because if it was bullish this is probably
setting up another continuation higher, especially if you start seeing these relative equal highs
forming where it paints the idea that this is retail resistance, so traders are going
to think that this is going to go lower and it starts to build up a lot more interest
in the form of buy side liquidity or buying interest at a high price even though those
traders may be framing the context of their trades as a short entry trying to make money
going lower, their protective stop if they choose to use one is going to be in the form
of a buy stop and this is where it's going to be at, so the market is going to want to
gravitate towards that especially if you start seeing the swing lows, not the one
in the month's time ignore that one, you start seeing the swing lows that are forming every
candle has a higher low to the left and higher low to the right, if they start building up
and every time they create a new one it's going higher that's underpinning on the marketplace
that's showing accumulation, it wants to go up because it wants to clean out all this
here plus we've been going up for a few days on the daily chart plus the sentiment is everybody
thinks it's been going down so they all want to sell short because they want to see a stock
market crash but what they are failing to realize is we've already went down below an
old low on the daily chart so now we're running back the other direction and anyone that's
trying to sell short unless it's a real quick intraday scalp they're having their clocks
cleaned so in the afternoon there's a trend and one of the built in characteristics of
the afternoon is there's mechanisms that are built in that help this market really accelerate
into the close and if you study the price action in your lower time frame charts you'll
see that there's a repeating phenomenon that's typically around 20 minutes to 4 and 10 minutes
to 4 and 4 o'clock and it's all based on market on close orders that's really what it is and
the algorithms will start spitting out really really aggressive pricing and forcing traders
to either cover or get out of trades and usually if it's going up it really just ramps up and
accelerates in that direction so while I really enjoy trading the morning session because
there's a lot of volatility and excitement if you're looking for if you know what your
daily bias is and we'll talk about that next week if you know what your daily bias is and
if you know what you're looking for in terms of range expansion on the daily chart know
what do I mean by that the daily candle do you expect it to trade higher or lower you're
not trying to predict you know every single daily candles close but you're trying to determine
do you think that the daily candle you're looking at forming today or what would be
forming tomorrow is it more likely to be expanding higher or lower if it's expanding higher in
your analysis that means you want to try to trade with the expectation to find a trade
in the afternoon based on the logic that was used in the morning so in other words think
about what I taught in forex the daily range okay creating a initial high of the day and
the low of the day here now this is not the time of London but this would be like what
I teach as a London low in a by day for forex this would be the low of the day then we consolidate
and then we get to New York continuation and it runs in the same direction that the London
session formed but this is not London this is all New York time so there's a little bit
of adjusting that needs to be taken into consideration which is why I made sure the
beginning of the video I said make sure your charts are set to New York time over here
it needs to be that okay and if you don't have it like that everything you're learning
here if it's at your local time in your local time zone it's going to be a mess so you need
to calibrate your charts on trading view to that and everything I'm showing you here is
the same thing every day every single day same thing so back to the homework assignment
I want you to think about outlining what the session was in the morning and then what did
the session do in the afternoon sometimes what you'll see is it'll be bullish in the
morning and then reverse in the afternoon or it'll be bullish in the morning and continuation
higher in the afternoon and you'll get like a measured move what's a measured move whatever
the morning move was it'll duplicate that twice so if it moves up 200 points in the morning the
afternoon could see another 200 points in addition to that and have a 400 point range or we could
have consolidation in the morning session and then it trends in the afternoon higher or lower okay
and I want you to go through your charts and look at that on an intraday basis do your charts like
this and I know it's a lot of work but you want to learn how to do it right this is how you do it
then study what the daily chart was showing days before when it had days that had these nice runs
like this and yesterday and previous Friday so it allows you to help find these big moves where
if you're looking at other like I'm not gonna say this to try to be mean-spirited because that's
not my intent here but I want you to compare and contrast like if you look around at all the folks
on YouTube and again this is not this is not me trying to be arrogant I just want you to understand
there's a stark contrast to what I'm teaching you here and what is predominantly shown in this area
of trading okay index futures you'll see traders that'll get in here and they get in a price like
that and then they're gonna make a big attempt to worry about a move like that and they'll put lots
of contracts on and you know trade this and have a whole lot of hype and anxiety about whether or
not it's gonna move in their favor and worry about their stop getting hit and all this stuff
and I don't want you thinking like that okay I don't want you thinking like that at all I
want you to think about how if this day was bullish for you say you had the benefit of
knowing it through analysis you felt that this was gonna go higher okay that's the case this
swing low here first swing low any importance after 130 this is really important 130 I'm looking
swing highs and swing lows for the afternoon session that's what I'm looking for it's the
same context that I use for the morning session I'm looking for swing highs and swing lows prior
to 830 I'm looking for the first one okay I'm not needing to go back days and days and days
I'm just looking for the first one it's not a complicated thing but at 130 that's usually
when I'm wanting to start trading the afternoon that's the earliest but I'm preferably looking
for a swing high and swing low to form at 130 why 130 because there's an algorithm macro that
starts running at 130 that's beyond the scope of this mentorship but just trust me there is
something going on that creates movement at 130 in the New York session okay in equity market so
when that occurs all we're looking for or what I'm looking for is a swing high and a swing low and
then that same basis of looking for a stop hunt in the morning like we described here I'm looking
for the same thing here it's it same thing so now think about this I'm I'm thinking that these stops
are in jeopardy because it's too clean the levels too clean straight line edges in the market they
don't tend to stay like that there's gonna be a disruption the markets been going higher hasn't
yes there's this pent-up aggression that this market wants to go higher but it's seeing short
term resistance here here it tried it a little bit here and then retraced inside the lunch hour
the algorithm reserved the price run until later in the day now watch what happens this swing low
here gets violated right there see that that swing low gets violated right there that small
little stop hunt is all that's necessary that will start what is called a buy program a buy
program is when the algorithms go into the process of spooling spooling is where it just
continuously keeps offering higher prices if it's a buy program it just keeps offering higher prices
it does not matter what the volume is it does not matter and I don't care who you know who
worked at the exchange I don't care trust me when I tell you if you go through the charts you're
gonna see this okay look at the volume that comes in sometimes it'll be good volume and another
reason why is this happening right that's that's your signature that's how you know that this is
being completely manipulated so if it's being manipulated doesn't it stand profitable for you
to know what it's likely to do not if you're gonna know it all the time you're not gonna know I don't
know it all the time but these things tend to repeat and if they repeat a majority of time not
every day but the majority of time if these things are in alignment if they start showing the same
fingerprints it's probably gonna pan out and then you can start doing long entries and then hold
for the close don't get in here and try to trade these little Mickey Mouse moves and worry about
them and over leverage and try to put more contracts on than your account can really weather because
if you don't know what you're doing cheap leverage discount leverage can murder you can absolutely
murder you and especially in these kind of markets they're very fast markets right now I'm
loving it but it's very quick violent volatility and if you don't know what you're doing you can
literally be dismantled very quickly expediently okay so inside this area the market creates a
swing low runs through this low stop hunt so the stops below here what cell stops by those cell
stops I know it feels scary but go through your chart you'll see many examples of this happening
it's the same thing took place over here by the cell stops that are resting below here and expect
this level to be taken out consolidation through lunch after 1 30 an afternoon wait for a swing
low to be violated and then rally what if you don't get a swing load it trades below it what do you
look for well you look for a move higher that's sudden displacement higher then look for a fair
value gap if it trades back down to the fair value gap you buy that there's your two patterns
that's it it's the only two patterns you need you don't need 15 different gimmicky names okay you
don't need breakers you don't need an order block see how easy that is very simple strategy very
very simple strategy you have a trade one way or the other and the logic has to be there for either
one of them to form now I was not in the e-mini S&P today I was trading NASDAQ so let's go over
to NASDAQ and I'm gonna save time and not put all the lipstick on the chart I hope you can allow
me that but here is 130 we have a swing low there and it's basically almost the same low as that one
so what's happening here what's that it's trading down below it see that look further to the left
what's that a fair value gap oh man it can't be that easy it can't be that easy these relative
equal highs what's above that buy sign liquidity okay watch I'm gonna drop into the one-minute
chart scrub back here to 130 and I don't need to do 20 contracts or 10 contracts to do like
a $20,000 day that's kind of like the flavor of the month right now and if you look at this low
and this low here what are those they're relative equal lows so that's gonna be viewed as what
support retail support and they're gonna buy those little runs here they're basically gonna
chase that so if you look at this through the scope of below this level they're sell stops and
you think it's gonna go higher like I believed it was gonna go higher today I want to be buying
those stops all right so say you're watching price it's meandering through through through
and then all of a sudden that swing low forms right there and we have this low here and we have
the sudden drop down when you see that if you're watching it on a like a one-minute chart that's
gonna look so dynamic so aggressive if you're zoomed in it's gonna feel like the floor has
just dropped out but that's exactly what you're looking for to buy now you see fellas out there
on YouTube you're gonna see by contrast there are folks out there that are trying to trade you know
just a handful of ticks with a lot of contracts that to me doesn't make any sense but if that
works for you then great okay but I want you to think about in comparison and by contrast what
seems more logical for you to feel it's worth more to pursue and study and learning how to do
something like that where it's risk a lot put a lot behind the trade and try to get just a little
bit of a move or now this is a demo account okay but I did trade live today too but just for the
purposes of teaching the content right there that low is the lowest candle it rallies all the way
up okay and then right here that was a close there's a better way to do this if you know what you're
looking for you can be very very precise about it you can be dialed in like nobody's business
like it is unbelievable in terms of the predictable nature of these markets especially these markets
because they're they're traded by a lot of institutions and a lot of professional traders
the manipulation that takes place in these markets is still there but it's not as well
vulgar or ruthless as it is sometimes in Forex the inner bank markets man they can really really
you know do you dirty quick and more frequently the futures market they tend to be a little bit
more cleaner a little bit more predictable much more nicer in their delivery now there are times
when reports come out or something you know unannounced comes into the world scene and causes
volatility when that occurs then you'll get that noisy look to price action just stand on the
sidelines wait for things to smooth out it may not be that same trading day it may require you a
day or maybe even a week let the markets go back in to sync and then they'll start delivering very
nice again but the the main thing I want you to take away is that it's showing entries like this
and exits and stuff it's not it's not all that much of a big deal okay but it becomes a sticking
point okay a stumbling block for people that want to try to learn how to do this because if you lay
it in front of them they have to have lots of contracts to do something to be profitable
in such a small little move to me it communicates that that person that's trying to trade like that
whether it's the person that created the system or someone that's trying to learn the system they
really have no idea how price works and how it books because if they did they wouldn't be
trying to take these little tiny little micro moves out of the marketplace they would be trading
like I'm showing you here so if you were to think to yourself hey I want to know what it's like to
be in a move where I can be comfortable knowing that the daily range is going to unfold and I'm
just going to submit to it well these markets offer that Forex offers it too but right now in
the last couple months really Forex is being rather funky okay and because of that we have
transitioned to index futures there are times of the year where I teach index futures trading
because they're predominantly more liquid and or if there's no real topic for me to teach to my
paid mentorship group I'll say I got nothing for you for Forex and then I'll point to something
in futures it may be a commodity market like last year I told everybody buy the gray markets they
were gonna have a huge bull market boom they went up it's a matter of knowing how to navigate the
price action okay but these markets here except for the summer months and that being like July
and August those months can be a little hit or miss but the rest of the year they tend to
be really nice markets so if you're looking to have your trading business framed on a asset
class that is really nice it's professionally delivered where it's not like a bucket shop you
know penny stock type market it's these markets are really nice they're very systematic in the
way they do things and they repeat but if you don't know what you're looking for or understanding
behind these mechanics that I'm outlining here at the very basic level then you can obviously
hurt yourself still so right away I'm showing you that there are times in the day that you want to
be looking for setups you're not trying to do 25 trades you're not trying to do 30 trades you're
not and you're trying to micro scalp you're looking for the real moves in the morning and
the real moves in the afternoon and preferably if you get one in the morning you don't trade in the
afternoon go to a demo and practice there don't give the money back to the marketplace especially
while you're you know you're new don't do that and I'm actually telling you not to trade with live
funds but I know a lot of you like to see things that are traded with a live account like it's a
real account that shows entries and and things of that nature and that's the things that I'm
doing this year okay I'm not gonna do it in 2023 I'm not gonna do it forever okay I did it that way
my students can feel at ease about it because even in my in my paid mentorship group I don't
trade live funds there because for my protection I'm doing what I'm showing you right here in a
demo but I've been showing live account trades this to prove that it works so hopefully you
found this insightful and until I talk to you on Thursday be safe.